[MUSIC PLAYING]
AKMAL ABDELFATAH: Developing
sustainable cities
is one of the major concerns
for planners around the world.
Sustainable
transportation systems
add vital elements of
a sustainable city.
Transportation planners
considered the [INAUDIBLE]
for public transportation
such as buses and light rail.
And growth of private
transportation,
such as passenger cars and
motorcycles as measures
of the level of sustainability
for a transportation system.
Developing countries
that experience increases
in income level are also
witnessing high increase
in population and vehicle
restoration rates.
For example, in Malaysia
there is an increase
of about one passenger car and
one motorcycle for each person
added to the population.
Such an increase in
private transportation,
is there a matching
in rate of increase
in public transportation system?
In Malaysia, there
have been no additions
to the rail system over
the past few years,
and only a very small
increase in bus registration
over the same period.
For each 1000 persons
increase in population,
there is an increase of
less than four buses,
including private
buses and public buses,
about 1000 passenger cars
and about 1000 motorcycles
added to the road network.
So why should
transportation planners
worry about such a situation?
Because there are several
negative impacts, including,
higher traffic congestion
levels, more air pollution,
greater noise levels, and
increase in accident rates.
The increase in
accident rates often
results in higher
fatality rates,
which is the focus
of this presentation.
What is a fatality rate,
and how it can be used?
The traffic fatality rate
represents the number
of deaths due to traffic
accidents put each 100,000
of population in any country.
It's one of the
major indicators used
to measure the level of traffic
safety on a road network.
Most developing countries
have higher fatality rates
than developed countries.
Malaysia has set its goal to be
among the developed countries
by the year 2020.
However, the current
fatality rate in Malaysia
is much higher than all
developed countries.
As shown in the illustration,
the fatality rate
in most of the
developing countries
is in the range of about three
to seven deaths per 100,000
people.
In Malaysia the rate jumps
to approximately 25 deaths
per 100,000 population.
Considering the countries
around Malaysia,
it's clear that some
countries like Singapore,
and Brunei have
fatalities rates that
are within the same range
as developed countries.
On the other hand,
as you can see here,
the fatality rate in
Malaysia is among the highest
in Southeast Asia.
In fact, the fatality
rate in Malaysia
is about five times
the fatality rate
in the closest neighboring
country, Singapore.
So, taking a closer look
at Malaysia's accidents,
it shows that the percentage
of motorcycles involved
in accidents is about
1.5%, while the percentage
of fatalities among
motorcyclists is about 60%
of the total fatalities.
What might be some reasons
for this high fatality
rate among the motorcyclists?
One of the major problems
with motorcyclists
in developing countries
is that they often
do not follow traffic laws.
They may ride between
traffic lanes,
a stop on pedestrian
crossing area,
or run a red light
at intersections,
as you can see from the video.
Such a behavior is an indication
of two main issues-- lack
of enforcement, and
lack of awareness.
So what do
motorcyclists say when
they are asked about their
view regarding wearing safety
helmets, and their perception
of high rate of fatalities
among motorcyclists?
It appears from the
presented information
that most motorcyclists
in Malaysia
are not aware of traffic
and safety regulations.
However, according to a traffic
safety expert, in Malaysia,
the main causes of accidents
are-- road user incompetence
and driver fatigue.
Road environment and vehicle
conditions are also mentioned.
The driver's awareness of
traffic safety regulations
are not given
enough consideration
in the expert's opinion.
MOHAMED SHAHARUDIN BIN LADEN:
During the implementation
of a system, they found out that
50% of traffic offenders that
are caught under the system
couldn't be [INAUDIBLE].
So this 50% is serious
loopholes in the implementation
of the system.
That's why, in November--
last November they
tried to enforce the
number of plates regulation
to ensure that the ES
system can work properly.
AKMAL ABDELFATAH: So,
what are the efforts
by the Malaysian government
to reduce traffic accidents?
According to one
of the officials
in the Malaysian Institute of
Road Safety Research, MIROS,
the following are
examples of the studies
to reduce traffic accidents
over the past 10 years.
Automated enforcement
system implementation,
such as using cameras
at intersections
to report traffic violations.
Implementation of community
based program on safety helmet.
Implementation of road
safety education in schools.
New driver training curriculum
based on learning outcomes.
However, these efforts to
reduce traffic accidents
and improve awareness
have not been
very successful at
achieving their objectives.
The last two Malaysian national
plans, covering the period
from 2006 to 2015, do
emphasize the development
of the public
transportation system.
However, these plans are
still being implemented.
Officials have indicated that
there are studies regarding
fatalities and some
recommendations for reducing
accidents, especially
for motorcyclists.
However, it seems that these
recommendations have not
had significant
impact in reducing
the motorcyclists fatality rate.
MOHAMED SHAHARUDIN BIN LADEN:
Why I changed my workplace
probably because there's no
public transport mode that
can move me from
home to my workplace,
so that my personal
experience why
I'm changing mode of transport.
As for right now, as
speaking of our land
transport especially
in the big cities,
I believe, yes,
they do have buses,
but most of public
in big cities depends
on-- and that the commuter.
The [INAUDIBLE] commuter is,
I believe it's overloaded.
They cannot fulfill the
public demands on it.
So the demand is sped up.
So the sped up choice,
either mode of transport,
and I believe that
motorcyclists is
some of the most very
popular choice for motor
transport among big
cities commuter compared
to [INAUDIBLE] of course.
AKMAL ABDELFATAH: The
following video shows part
of an interview with the
assistant director of the Road
Safety Department for Malaysia,
indicating some of the causes
of accidents and
suggested solutions.
MOHAMED SHAHARUDIN
BIN OSMIN: It's
an offence for drivers under
the influence of drugs to drive.
Even to sit in the
car is an offense.
But there's a difference between
when the police enforce it.
When the police find
out that drivers driving
under the influence
of drugs, they
will be charged under something
related to drug possession.
It's not road traffic
offences, but it's
related to drug offences.
So it's a big difference
in terms of enforcement.
And currently, there's
no region type of policy
to tackle this thing.
For example, we do have
a continuous meeting
with the Ministry of
Works on the importance
of having dedicated motorcycle
lane to separate motorcyclists
from other road users.
But the main issue,
whenever it came
to bid up the new dedicated
motorcycle lane, it's lost.
So whatever causes the
obstacle, then it never can--
as we are the Road Safety
Panel, so we cannot do anything,
because it falls under the
Ministry of Work jurisdiction
that can build the
dedicated motorcycle lane.
AKMAL ABDELFATAH: The following
are some short-term strategies
that can reduce the number
of traffic fatalities
among the motorcyclists.
Enforcing stricter
licensing procedure
for motorcycles-- for
example, increasing
the age of receiving a
motorcycle driving license,
canceling some of the old
models of motorcycles,
and increasing
registration fees.
Implementing higher
levels of enforcement
through the use of
technology-- for example,
by using automated
systems at traffic signals
and for speed control.
Such systems can reduce
the traffic violations
shown in the videos
in this presentation.
Apply tougher penalties
for traffic violations,
especially for motorcyclists.
improve awareness
through campaigns
that educate motorcyclists about
traffic and safety regulations.
In addition to these
short-term strategies targeted
at reducing
motorcycle fatalities,
cities should also
make a concerted effort
to improve the public
transportation infrastructure,
to ensure long-term
sustainability.
What are the benefits of
having a higher [INAUDIBLE]
for public transportation?
It can result in lower delays,
less pollution, fewer accidents
and fatalities, and a more
sustainable transportation
system.
What are the main deficiencies
in the public transportation
system in Malaysia that
deter people from using it?
Primary drawbacks are the lack
of connectivity, low frequency,
and less flexibility as
compared to motorcycles.
INTERVIEWER: If there
is a good bus and rates
that would provide
reasonable flexibility
and reasonably priced-- compared
with the price [INAUDIBLE]
would he use that?
We know it's not
there in JB now,
but if that system would exist,
would that change his mind,
or would he use it?
INTERPRETER:
[SPEAKING MALAYSIAN]
MAN ON STREET:
INTERPRETER: He would
choose-- yes, he
says if the system is
there, he would just
use that [INAUDIBLE] system.
INTERVIEWER: So what is the
most important thing for him
to see on that system to use?
What would be his
[INAUDIBLE] priority?
Is it the cost or
the flexibility?
Is it the timing, the frequency?
What is his most
important element
to use the public transport?
INTERPRETER:
[SPEAKING MALAYSIAN]?
MAN ON STREET:
[SPEAKING MALAYSIAN].
INTERPRETER: Time would be
his most priority-- time.
INTERVIEWER: Thank you
very much for that.
MAN ON STREET: Thank you.
INTERVIEWER: Appreciate
it very much.
Thank you.
MOHAMED SHAHARUDIN BIN
OSMIN: Under the purview
of [INAUDIBLE] area, which
is under the jurisdiction
of Ministry of Transport,
Ministry of [INAUDIBLE],
and also Land Public
Transport Commission,
there's a target of increasing
the number of public transport
in the market, where they
are promoting increasing
numbers of service--
for example, the taxi
numbers, the drivers numbers,
for example, this, for example.
Right now, the focus is
increasing the service
to meet the demand.
Because right now, the challenge
is that the public is eager.
We believe that the
public's are willing to use
the public transport, but
the option is not there.
AKMAL ABDELFATAH: In
light of that fact--
that the majority of
traffic fatalities
are occurring among
motorcyclists-- what
are some possible
long-term strategies that
can increase the use of
public transportation?
Which, in turn, may
reduce the fatality rate
among the motorcyclists
in Malaysia
and other developing countries
facing similar problems.
Providing sufficient funds
can allow local authorities
to develop the public
transportation system,
improving the
connectivity, frequency,
and punctuality of public
transportation system.
Utilizing intelligent
transportation systems
applications, such as
transit signal priority,
implementing an attractive
and fair pricing system
that can encourage people to
use public transportation,
considering transit
oriented development
concepts for new developments.
In conclusion, rapidly growing
cities in developing countries
have populations
that are growing
at a much higher rate than
their public transportation
infrastructure.
This leads to an increase in the
use of private transportation.
In cases where the percentage
of motorcycles is high,
the cities witness a high
traffic fatality rate.
The proposal strategies
in this presentation
can benefit these cities.